besides brian keating is a hypocrite and
he would love to
accept nothing more than a nobel prize
if offered it
the most common criticism that i get uh
regarding my book or some of my speeches
is that i didn't actually lose the nobel
prize in other words you have to win
something in order to or be eligible to
win something
or be in a final competition like the
world series
in order to lose the world series lose
the nobel prize
and therefore you might have to have
actually lost it
in order to make a criticism of the
institution itself and i always point
out yeah i guess that's right we can't
really criticize the president of the
united states
unless we ran for president of the
united states and and effectively lost
it
um but we're not talking politics we
always avoid politics on the into the
impossible podcast
we are not a safe space we are a space
for academic freedom and ideas
and assaying claims from experiment from
science
but i think all will agree that today's
guest
professor carl hagan not carl sagan carl
hagen
of the university of rochester has a
legitimate claim
that he indeed lost the nobel prize and
i'm quoting from my book losing the
nobel prize the book of the same name
a section about him and my late great
mentor
dr jerry garlneck who is my professor of
advanced quantum mechanics and group
theory at
brown university back in the 90s when i
was uh fortunate enough to be in jerry's
class
jerry and carl today's guest worked very
closely together
and jerry was one of the sweetest people
i ever ever knew and one of my greatest
influences
as you can tell when you read losing the
nobel prize available in every format
possible
and i want to read the chapter two
sections that are relevant to
the guest today which is carl hagen that
appear in my book so they both appear
i i always say there's three chapters in
my book out of 11 chapters that deal
with the nobel prize i helpfully
color-coded them gray or norton my
publisher allowed me to color code them
in gray
in order to easily identify in case you
want to skip
but i hope you won't want to skip the
sections about nobel prize reformation
which i call
three lenses that are broken and in need
of repair in order to
restore a noble vision le
vision and so one of these chapters the
first one
is called uh it's chapter five it's
called broken lens number one
the nobel prize is credit problem so i
have this cute little thing
credit cash collaboration these are the
three different
uh pillars that are broken these lenses
that are broken
in need of repair to restore this noble
vision and i quote from a nobel prize
winner george bernard shaw i can forgive
alfred nobel
for having invented dynamite but only a
fiend in human form could have invented
the nobel prize
uh so he was always quick quick with a
quip
and uh in chapter five i go on i talk
about jerry gerald like my
my wonderful mensch of a teacher at
brown university taught me so much about
not only group theory which was his
ostensible job but taught me about life
and what it's like to be a professor
and what it's like to aspire to
greatness and and sometimes come up
short i miss uh jerry tremendously
but uh when the section about this is
regarding the so-called higgs boson
which is the subject of today's
guest appearance uh and it
revolves around the incident that
surrounded the 2013 nobel prize award
ceremony which was
awarded to just two of the rightful
perhaps seven
contestants that means five people lost
the nobel prize
in one form or another so i'm talking
about why this is so bad and what's
wrong with uh what happened
uh in the 2013 nobel prize and this
affected today's guest carl
hagen as i'll point out uh so i say but
this was not the troubling aspect of the
2013 nobel prize
this this referring to the long elapsed
time between the prize
uh being awarded in 2013 and the
prediction
of the effect for which it was
ostensibly awarded
uh to englert and higgs what trouble
means that the committee allows the
prize to go to three scientists
at most it's another broken lens which i
will discuss in chapter 13.
yet approximately 6 000 scientists
worked on the two experiments atlas and
cms at the lhc
and even with this arbitrary limitation
to three prize winners the prize was
awarded to only two physicists
despite there being at least three other
living physicists who played
a significant role in the discovery one
of the overlooked physicists was jerry
geralnick one of my mentors at brown
university his official job was to teach
me advanced topics in quantum mechanics
but i learned much more from him most of
all what it takes to lead
young scientists in their profession
jerry was a brilliant scientist
and a mensch his paper co-authored by
carl hagen and tom kibble appeared in
the same 1964 edition
of physical review letters as anglert
and robert
browde's paper many physicists regard
grounic
hagan and kibble's paper as at least
equal to the contemporaneous papers by
englert and brought
and by higgs of all the papers that
could claim priority in predicting
the boson theirs was the one that truly
solved the particularly
vexing technical issue of the so-called
unwanted goldstone bozone
but jerry never seemed bitter about
losing a share of the 2013 nobel prize
after the award to englert and higgs
jerry said it's a wonderful feeling of
great satisfaction and amazement
we started off to solve an interesting
and challenging and abstract problem
we were surprised by the answer that
turned up and that really summarizes
jerry's attitude and from what i've
learned of of carl hagen himself
professor hagen
uh he too has this this notion that this
that the prize is secondary in
importance but i do think the prize
needs to be reformed and i
plan to talk about that and by the time
you listen to this i will have already
recorded
the interview with professor hagan i
hope you enjoy it as much as i did
from all the research i've done on him
he could not be
any more impressive than he actually is
how much he's accomplished he still goes
to work every day this is
more than 50 years after the uh
the publication of the paper which
rightfully uh should have won him the
nobel prize again he is
very much alive he should live and be
well to age 120 as we say
and uh the last part i want to read from
chapter
chapter 13 it involves the broken lens
that i call the nobel prizes
collaboration problem
which uh is in part about the pernicious
effect of the nobel prize
to uh to cause collaborations which are
for healthy to collapse and uh it's
really a quite a detrimental problem
that collaborations and ideas which
should be most
kind of coming to fruition just at the
moment that they get
recognized these these can sometimes
collapse under
the weight of university public
relations machines media
mail storms and so forth and all of this
could be rectified
and all the nobel prize winners i've
talked to this is the one thing they all
agree upon
uh is that it should go to more people
and in the case of
of the nobel prize awarded to um awarded
to just to brought and
englert and to heggs i think it easily
could have been rectified to award
at least all the living theorists and
hopefully or or
in in preference my preference would
have been include some of the
experimentalists maybe all the
experimentalists
what law of nature you know prevents all
the people that participated from
sharing
some portion of the prize monetarily and
by prestige after all that's what
happens with the nobel peace prize
thousands of people can potentially win
it has not diminished
that aspect of the peace prize has not
led to any diminishment
of how often it's sought out so the
collaboration problem broken lens 3
says imagine the outcry begins by saying
imagine the outcrop the legendary 2016
us men's olympic
4 by 200 meter freestyle olympic team
michael phelps ryan lochte
connor dwyer and townley haas
obliterated their competition and came
in first
but only haas lochte and dwyer received
medals with nothing not even a silver
medal
for phelps unfair you would say and
you'd be right
and i go in and talk about how you know
this left out this mechanism
which should be rightfully called and
even peter higgs himself would call it
the a b e g h h k
t h mechanism standing for philip
anderson robert brown francois
englert jerry garalnick carl hagan
peter higgs tom kibble and gerald gerard
tahuft
all except for brown were still living
in 2013.
so um i'm very excited to uh
welcome you all after this lengthy
introduction i do hope you'll
pick up a copy of my book uh i'll also
help and enjoin upon you to please leave
a review of the podcast
on apple itunes or subscribe on apple
itunes leave a rating and review
so we can get more great guests we have
some nobel prize winners coming up in
the very near future
on the into the impossible podcast and
i'll be sharing some more stories from
the book
uh and some of the adventures as this
nobel
uh annunciation season as i call it uh
comes to the forefront so i hope you'll
enjoy the ride and stay tuned it's
pretty wild it culminates
on coronation day which is december 10th
not alfred nobel's birthday
the day he died way back 1896 and that's
when the nobel prizes are awarded each
year
it's a national holiday i'm kind of
curious if the nobel prizes will even be
awarded this year
in person due to covid uh sweden has had
a different approach i always say from
the rest of the western
hemisphere uh in europe uh with regard
to covid
uh we'll see what happens leave your
comments do you think in the chat below
do you think there'll be an in-person
nobel prize
ceremony this year on december 10th
alfred nobel's death day
it would be unprecedented but these are
unprecedented times
thank you so much for bearing with me in
this long-winded introduction
to a most remarkable individual and i
just want to take great advantage
of his time because he's such a special
special treasure
a living legend dr carl hagan
any sufficiently advanced technology is
indistinguishable from the magic
[Music]
it is such a thrill such a treat to be
speaking with
none other than professor cr
carl richard or dick hagan who was born
on the 2nd of february 1937.
he's a professor of physics at the
university of rochester he's noted for
many many contributions
including uh fundamental contributions
to the
to the standard model of particle
physics and
the uh the the discovery of a mechanism
related to spontaneous symmetry breaking
conventionally known as
the higgs mechanism but we're going to
get into that because i think it's
incredibly important
issues of collaboration and issues of
attribution within all of science but in
particular
in the work that was done in this field
that's so near and dear to my heart
uh so he's had so many awards
uh i can't even list all the things he's
worked on and i think i'll need another
podcast with you
to discuss uh to discuss things like the
rnf bomb effect the churn simon's
work that you've done but uh to begin
with i wanted to say that you got your
phd
your masters and your bachelor's from
mit and at mit your
your doctoral thesis is in quantum
electrodynamics you've been at
university of rochester since 1963
i understand you go in there all the
time you won an award for excellence in
teaching
you've won uh many honorary doctorates
from uh from different institutions
referee outstanding referee from the
american physical
society winner of the sakurai prize the
aps fellow award
uh just such an outstanding uh list of
contributions we need
like three podcasts to introduce you
fully how are you doing today dick
i'm doing pretty well uh considering the
climate out there the pandemic
and increasing age
which slows me down a bit but all things
i guess i'm doing okay so i wrote about
you i've known about you of course my
whole professional career
and i studied under uh none other than
your close friend uh for many many
decades and i remember
our mutual friend jerry geraldine
speaking so highly of you as i write in
my book
losing the nobel prize uh about the this
invention that is is known as the as the
higgs mechanism
uh the higgs boson but that higgs
himself allegedly peter higgs calls it
the
a b e g h h
k apostrophe t h mechanism standing for
phillip anderson robert brought francois
glare jerry garalnick
carl hagan peter higgs tom kibble and
gerald tuft
all except for brought i write we're
living in the year 2013 when the nobel
prize was awarded to
to uh higgs and angler and we'll
certainly get into that but before we do
i want to uh take you back a little bit
uh farther in time than 2013 and take
you back to your
to your childhood one of your friends we
were discussing before we started
recording
that i'm sort of related to you in a way
maybe influentially
through your uh friendship with one of
the greatest uh
you know scientists that i ever knew and
greatest teachers that i ever knew
and that's uh jerry geraldine and it
says here that uh and this is a book by
ian sample i'm holding it up called
massive the hunt for the god particle
and on page 60 of this wonderful book we
talk about the difference
uh in jerry's life when and and you come
into the story he talks about meeting
you
in cambridge massachusetts a group of
physicists was circling around the same
problem that higgs brought and angler
were already working on
none knew that uh what the others were
up to or even that they were in
competition
for what became one of the greatest
prizes in modern physics
as undergraduates jerry growlnick and
dick hagan were inseparable groundling
went to harvard while hagen went to mit
but the two institutions shared lectures
that they both attended the two were
awestruck by julian schwinger the
harvard physicist
whose work shaped quantum
electrodynamics in the 40s
when schwinger arrived for a lecture he
started writing down equations at the
top left corner of the board
and kept writing until he reached the
bottom right at which point
he stopped quietly strolled out of the
room
and left his directors seemed
impenetrable at first but persevere
and the man's genius was clear and i
think uh
the friendship is what i first want to
get into
how did you and jerry meet i've never
fully understood
the actual meeting between the two of
you guys that was so momentous for
physics and for you personally
yes well uh we both went to mit as
undergrads
and he's from iowa and i was from the
city of chicago and uh
at mit you're all mixed in with every
other major and so forth your first year
and it's only as a sophomore you get to
uh
meet your fellow would-be physicists and
uh jerry sometimes reminded me the way
he became aware of me was we were in our
sophomore e m class and according to him
anyway
i was bitching to the professor about
something or other that he'd uh
not give me credit for and so forth and
he
formed maybe some adverse opinion about
me but nonetheless we made a connection
and uh just grew and stayed
like topsy it just grew so uh
we've been uh pals ever since
uh when we finished our bachelor's
degree
uh yes uh he
went to harvard i stayed at mit i guess
i'm a creature i've had but i like the
things that i'm familiar with so
that was familiar to me but uh that
didn't end it
uh we went to
schwinger's lectures as you uh uh
remarked
and since i mentioned about the elongate
relation between
us how also i could remark that
i'm a grandchild of schwinger because
his student johnson was my advisor at
mit
but okay so uh anyway
we uh continued uh our association we
went to the schwinger lectures
uh religiously and we
sampled the social scene there in
cambridge
uh weight stances and all that
stuff he went to uh
london uh so
i went to rochester and uh
so how'd i end up in london well i did a
paper
at that time which i had gave a catchy
title to
uh elementary particles as elementary
particles kind of sounds kind of
redundant
but uh uh it was sort of a play on
uh the work of jeffrey chu
uh and he was of course popularizing the
bootstrap theory nothing was more
fundamental than anything else
just they brought each other into
existence and so forth
and i didn't get particularly attracted
by that point of view so i did this
paper elementary part of settlement
particles and um
the pre-print got a little bit of
tension at uh imperial college where
jerry was
and no doubt he says them well leave my
old pal and you can get him to come here
on the cheap so
why not do that so i went
to london and um i
actually stayed with the ground like
sarah and their uh
nice little pad in hempstead and uh
well that was um good we drove into work
every day and vice versa and uh
had plenty of time to talk about the
things that we were
dealing with yeah and you mentioned uh
schwinger
and um i think it was uh pretty
interesting maybe a little bit of
foreshadowing as sample writes in
in massive he said tensions over credit
run particularly high when the work in
question is worthy of a nobel prize
and i should stop and say you know my
friend eric weinstein and i have talked
about this
there are certain awards where the nobel
prize gives
gives um kind of uh confers upon the
recipient
a sort of aura and honor and then there
are prizes
uh like this award that you participated
so crucially
and inextricably with that i think give
prestige to the prize
and i think uh a similar event happened
with
uh with uh schwinger and and feynman
and tomonga and he writes about that in
in the in the books uh massive sample
he says stephen weinberg said it was a
pity the nobel committee failed to award
freeman dice in the prize
for his contribution to sorting out
quantum electrodynamics in the 1940s
and of course uh you know i knew freeman
very well he would come here
in the in the winters in the princeton
winters to escape those rather
and he would come he was a member of the
jason's that met here in san diego and
la jolla
and he never seemed bitter about it but
uh it was the kind of thing that he
almost felt like
at one point i felt like he said maybe
something to the effect that he was glad
he never got it because
now everybody asked him how does it feel
not to win a nobel prize
and uh i think you know as i said the
contributions that you made are so
inextricable
to this
[Music]
i want to take it back how does an idea
like the mechanism that you conceived of
which in many ways you know
it's always they say better to have a
third party praise you
so you don't really know me uh it's the
first time we're meeting but i'm gonna
praise you and say that the
contributions that you and jerry and tom
kibble made are perceived by many many
people
physicists among them myself included as
being superior in a way because it
avoided
uh unwanted features so first can we
take a step back
what inspired you to come up with this
ghk mechanism what was the
the collaboration like between the three
of you
and was it a case of a lone genius among
you or the three geniuses working
together that just inspiration came
what prompted you to come up with this
phenomenal fantastic mechanism that
underpins all of
all of modern physics yes well uh
mary had been involved in this before
i arrived and uh he was thinking about
it
and there's a paper he she did
and not to embarrass
him but he said well this paper was
at least subsequently said this paper
was wrong so he's still struggling with
this
and uh so it was on his uh
agenda list and i arrived and
we started talking about it from the
get-go
and uh it went on and on
and uh at the point at which
uh kibble uh joined is a bit
vague in my recollection now but uh
he uh came in and he's uh
a very smart uh deep guy and uh
certainly
uh contributed to the project and um
there's uh there's one thing which
was very significant maybe i see you
smiling maybe you know what i'm talking
to get to
because it was just as we were about to
mail off our paper to fizzrev letters
uh tom comes in and says oh look i've
just found these two papers by
fountain angler and higgs and so forth
and
uh and the spirit of being an honest uh
researcher yes we said we we should
include them now i wouldn't have had any
regrets
if we got the thing off before time came
in with these papers
but that's the history of it and that uh
act uh dogged the whole
politics of the uh
symmetry breaking mechanism for
50 years so uh
there's that aspect of it which
has a little bit of unpleasantness in my
memory but uh so be it
as they say now it is what it is yes
it is and and i think you know like my
friend freeman and
uh i don't know if you ever got to know
freeman but he
uh he would be the type you know as i
thought with jerry and you
and and tom that that the
prize would benefit from the prestige of
having awarded it to you and we'll get
into the politics of these things
in just a little bit but um but i think
i want to make a couple points for
experts out there we have a lot of
physicists that listen to this podcast
we've had five nobel
laureates on the podcast they all listen
to it uh
and we have uh just you know the best
and brightest uh you don't have to be a
nobel prize winner to come on the show
as uh as i prove all the time but
but i want to point out some things for
the experts because we have an awful lot
of them
and that why in my mind the
worst thing that the nobel prize can do
is rewrite history
and in fact i think it does that a lot
and it does it in a way that's very
pernicious to the public's
understanding and appreciation of
science to the extent that this
public knows about science they might
know about neil degrasse tyson or
somebody like this
or einstein sitting above you in the
back of your office there uh but they
won't uh
and they know about the nobel prize but
beyond that they really don't know that
much so there's a lot of
pressure on neil degrasse tyson or uh
the late great stephen
hawking for example had the same
pressure but the nobel prize committee
has this pressure every year and i think
that they often don't live up to it
and i'm speaking about this this uh
attribute that
even the nobel prize winners i've had on
my show have recognized as a serious
lacuna in the prize and that's the way
that it apportions credit
and it rewrites history and so first of
all i want to point out why
the uh the why we're not no one's saying
that higgs didn't deserve
you know accolades and attention but i
think to point out
uh the fact some of these facts that
your paper which i'm going to call ghk
uh is considered by most physicists and
i'm an experimentalist i'm just a simple
experimentalist but
but uh i've studied it and and my fellow
theorists tell me this that
the paper that you wrote is the most
complete one and even though
it was published a few weeks later as
you say it was due to the fact that you
were acting as good scholars
and that you were being intellectually
rigorous and acting with academic
you know ethics you were acting in an
ethical fashion so that's one thing
you guys had a massless boson and uh and
it showed how the goldstone theorem
you know certainly was not complete and
in the sense was was a failure
maybe we can talk about this so brought
and angler don't have this
uh boson but can you talk about the
goldstone and the mat the massless boson
and
why is that so important to your
mechanism
the master well there's the
masses boson which is predicted by the
goldstone theorem which was
the big problem and how to get rid of it
uh there's a other thing that in the
model that
we all considered uh you
take the four degrees of freedom which
are two
uh pairs and you combine in such a way
that
three of them go together to give
a massive particle and you have this
other one
left over and we didn't put in an
explicit mass term
and that would have been a a great thing
if we had
said it's important but that to us was
not the important thing the important
thing was
uh showing that the
uh massless gauge boson
could absorb this other one and become a
massive uh vector measurement so
uh that's uh what we tried to do
and uh we missed a uh
a point there regrettably but it was not
the important point in our view of it
and then the other thing that's kind of
interesting is that from the history in
this book
and in other books about the same
subject
it was clear that higgs himself didn't
have the boson until
uh nambu said to basically put it in
there and namboo famous nambo
i forget his first name but he was the
referee i believe
that the lore goes of higgs's paper
right so it was sort of like
uh your teacher correcting the homework
in some sense again we're not casting
aspersions on
anything that higgs did but uh but you
know the question of
of how this same mechanism comes to be
attributed to the name of a person
you know some people it could be it
could be the nambu bozon which i guess
he already has his own bozo well
when the time comes for me to uh
discourse on
why it's called the higgs boson uh
i have something to say so let's let's
do that then let's let's talk about why
it isn't called that because i have i
have
i think it's caused more harm than
almost any other
thing named in physics but please go on
okay well
we had a conference here in rochester
particle physics
conference uh the fellow who ran
rochester particle physics was uh
bob marshak and he was a great
conference organizer
and uh so he had this conference and he
invited a lot of
good people and uh one of the people
that came was
ben lee and ben lee was the guy who
uh referred to it as the higgs boson
and uh he made history that's the uh
way it's been ever since and uh
so um unfortunately but
uh that is the history of it
and when we look at the uh the kind of
way that
jerry would always tell me and and he
would just say it as an aside this is in
the 90s so this is decade before decades
before
the actual award it was decades before
the you know large hadron collider was
even constructed
and he used to say even back then that
the most important
uh you know relations to learn in
physics are public relations
and that you know he always suspected
that
uh that there was a lot of forces
working on behalf
of peter higgs to tell a story and i
always say to my students
you know it's almost as important in
terms of succeeding in physics
to know how to present your research to
present your findings which also
requires that you know the history of
your field
i don't know about your students but a
lot of my students are they don't
have a good grasp of the history of
physics it's not part how we teach
things instead
we tend to teach things in the following
way there was this problem
then einstein came along and fixed it
and then he won a nobel prize for this
uh feynman had a solution to this uh to
this
problem uh we'll check and and and
others had the solution
uh uh to this problem and they fixed it
and they won a nobel prize i call it
you know pedagogy by prize and i i think
that's endemic i don't know
you know why we have this fascination
with the nobel prize
but it was clear to jerry that having
not been as savvy politically and
publicly
relations wise i think he felt that hurt
him going back
to the 60s when we were working on this
the phrase nobel prize never once
crossed our
our discussions it was uh just something
that we were dimly aware of it
and uh i don't think we really
grasped at the time the uh
ultimate import of all this yes we knew
that
people were working on this important
people were working on it so
it must be something good in it so we
could uh
do something good and maybe enhance our
careers by working on it as well
but uh the nobel prize it was just uh
something out there in the void and it
just uh
did not figure into our reckonings at
all
and uh it was only
decades later in in from my perspective
anyway
that this even uh evolved into an issue
or maybe jerry
uh was uh thinking about this
almost as soon as we finished the
project but to me no i was just
a project it was good and uh what's the
next thing to work on
yeah that's uh maria mayer behind my
shoulder over here she was at ucsd
at the when she won the 1963 nobel prize
in physics and she said
uh i don't really care so much it was
more fun doing the physics than winning
the prize
but of course prizes are important they
they play a role
in um in establishing priorities
in physics in departments even in
countries and i wonder
did you ever notice a kind of pressure
not only coming from
say edinburgh where where higgs was i
believe to
but beyond all of europe and basically
to sort of
try to frame the the higgs
with that name especially for the
prestige of
of european physics at perhaps the
expense of american physics what
what do you make of that is that is that
a real phenomenon are
just being paranoid as an american well
i'm being paranoid as
a practitioner but i
heard things uh that this was
going on and i think i hope i'm not
mistaking it here but
i think i heard that tuft was one of the
leaders and saying
there's got to be a european prize
so we recognize that there are certain
forces
against us another thing
i'm not sure of but i was told by jerry
that
edinboro had a person who was just uh
employed to
help peter higgs on his way
so you know there are these forces which
we didn't have available to us but uh we
knew that they were out there there are
all these you know kind of very large
spreads coming out of cern nowadays as
they're advocating for
uh newer and some say more expensive and
faster collider experiments maybe we can
talk about that right now
as we as we talk about what's to come in
particle physics do you see
uh what what some have noted in
in in physics today is sort of a drought
since uh the discoveries that you
participated in
in the 60s uh the great work in the 70s
in theoretical particle physics
and somehow much less coming out that's
new and original
i mean the higgs is certainly the
biggest discovery of of course there are
many experimental discoveries in the 80s
uh rubia and others um uh and in quark
physics
letterman and uh um and others but
but in terms of new and original physics
do you feel
as some say there's been almost a
drought in
uh new fundamental particle physics
ideas
that can be tested by new and larger and
more expensive particle accelerators
well uh i'm not an experimentalist
and i'm not even a phenomenologist
uh whatever that is but uh
so i've been once or twice removed
from all these uh
details of advancement in the
world of experimental particle physics
uh
i haven't been pulled over by any
uh breakthrough in
theoretical physics that appeals to my
sense of what the
universe should be like so
i shared the view that
yes there's been sort of a darth of uh
progress
in in this field so uh regrettably but
and it my short-sightedness is possibly
to blame
and my increasing uh
agent removal from the scene of active
work on this and
are there sorts of um parallels in the
sense that
it might be a very exciting time i mean
i'm curious on your perspective on
things like string theory
or theories of everything for the simple
fact that you know there's been a lot of
interest lately and new
uh new and improved you know uh theories
of everything and i think
i'd like to know from you what i think
people are so interested and why do you
think
uh this particle which you know as ian
sample calls it the god particle leon
letterman called it that but i think
i think there's a backstory behind the
name the god particle can you explain
how it got that name and then i have a
follow-up after that
well i don't know any
great detail about the origin of the
name but
when letterman came out with that uh
i was pleased i mean it seemed like a
bit of excessive public relations but
nonetheless it was good it was
always good to say to think anyway
that i had some kind hand in the
addition of the god particle to the
elementary particle zoo
and i
don't have any uh uh
particular uh
of course i wanted back in the
subsequent realm the
string theory well uh i never got into
it
one i guess the the uh backing for it
always seemed to be a bit strange to me
and uh
i didn't have the deep mathematics that
uh
was required in order to contribute to
this in a meaningful way so
i just sort of uh took the uh
attitude that uh well let it come
forth show us what it can do in their
other
physicists of note who have said yeah
predict something
and uh i've been dating and uh there it
is it's
uh it's laid fallow and
it's safe by whether it's part of the
uh particle physics theory of 50 years
from now
i'm skeptical but i have no uh
nothing to lose if it is some say that
uh
that he named it that letterman uh named
it that because
uh he actually intended to call it the
god d-a-m-n
particle uh because it sort of had these
very bizarre and mysterious properties
in what sense is the is the higgs a
unique
you know kind of notion what makes it in
this particle and this mechanism
so unique and interesting and why has it
the effect that you that you
came up with and devised invented
has such persistence and then i want to
ask you uh actually
you don't have to answer that question
let me ask you a first question dick i'm
sorry to interrupt but
um what is uh you know what is in your
mind
is something like your mechanism is that
created is that discovered
you know we say about mathematics i've
had jim simons on the podcast uh
eminent mathematician and scientist and
he believes math is both invented and
discovered but what about a theoretical
idea in physics
well uh is it made or is it discovered
well
it had had to be there it's uh the
theories
uh of uh of the elementary particles
gauge theories of
uh elementary particles they foundered
on the
issue of uh of mass and it was a
um it was a killing problem that uh
confronted us
and uh had to be discovered
unfortunately
the mathematics uh allowed
for the insertion of the ideas that we
uh
came up with and uh it emerged now
uh we did one particular model
uh simplest model one that all of us
have done and there might have been more
complicated models and no
no doubt a lot of them have been used in
subsequent years
but a lot of us think physics is
basically simple one should uh
be elucidated by discovering uh things
in
very simple models and okay it was
i think so uh that's uh
how it came to pass and uh my
view of it i guess and what do you make
of um
of the kind of the
extremely long period of time that it
took between
prediction by you and your colleagues
and friends
to discovery uh we often hear things
like trust the science and trust
scientists etc
but what happens when it takes 50 what
56 years or something like that
between prediction and discovery what
how do you persevere for such a long
period of time
with the with the with confidence or
were you nervous
how did you possibly handle that
pressure for decades and decades
well to be quite honest it was not
uh something that i thought about it all
something which i look back upon is a
interesting uh productive physics
problem which
uh jerry and i worked
on uh was there gonna be an ultimate uh
proof of what we had done and i guess as
you
uh remarked a bit back uh
the lhc came along and made all this
possible and then
people started thinking that okay we
could uh
find the scalar boson uh
i don't call it eggs but scalable
but uh i'll start doing that too then
there was all this talk of
nobel prize and oh okay that's that's
great
but we started counting up to sex and
the arithmetic wasn't uh working out for
us so uh
that uh wasn't too promising
right and then uh and i would be remiss
if i didn't ask you
uh if there was a hagen prize uh for all
i know maybe there is one
or there will be one uh you've won so
many accolades and awards but
let's say you were devising a prize that
had the same goals uh abstractly that
alfred nobel
had which is to recognize contributions
by science to
the betterment of all mankind as he put
it
what the how would you change the rules
what what differences would you make or
are they fine just as is
well the rules aren't fine the way they
are but from my perspective
it would have to be certain changes in
uh who's eligible how many are eligible
and so forth but i think nobel's
original charge is uh
something that i would be hard-pressed
to
improve upon and uh i
am always reluctant to try to
force people in a certain direction that
appeals to
my particular sense of order by saying
oh here's this big prize you'll get if
you
uh show that what i'm thinking about is
correct
so no uh if there could be
a uh nobel prize prime or something like
that
that would be the uh route that i would
um advocate and uh again
with the spikening of the
rules it shouldn't be
one two or three or four five six
and uh should how do you recognize
things which are these huge
collaborations uh
which you can uh relate to uh even
better
than i so uh yeah the
issue of how you uh bring those into the
fold
would have to be uh carefully thought
out and
that's not something which i have done
and no one's asked me
towards that's uh where we are
okay um well that certainly
uh comports with what many of my
colleagues and friends uh say as well
i i resonate with what you're saying i
want to
finish up in the last few minutes by
asking you uh some questions about
your philosophy and the meaning of life
as a physicist at least
from a perspective of a great career a
long career i
wish you even longer in this practice
you won a teaching award for outstanding
teaching uh
not that long ago i want to ask you what
is it about teaching that you love
is there something that particularly
appeals to you about
teaching itself well i think it's the
interaction with the students that
uh i enjoy so much
and uh before the last couple decades
i've been teaching a course in
undergraduate quantum mechanics upper
level
and uh i
had a certain amount of fame in the
department for my uh
difficult problems i gave them i mean
they weren't beyond their ken
but they taxed them to the utmost and
uh the students liked that and uh
it was a great part of my uh
teaching career and the
thing is uh now that has been made more
difficult because of
the pandemic and actually uh it
caused me to decide i'm going to retire
now i'm i'm not uh
into this and uh if i
can't uh interact with the students uh
except
remotely or with a mask it's
not something i can possibly continue
continuum
so the department put its resources into
someone who was
more amenable to that new style of
teaching
it's very challenging and i you know i'm
not
particularly optimistic i'm generally an
optimistic person but i'm not
terribly optimistic about this finding a
cure etc
and and certainly you should you should
take care of your health you're in
an older age bracket obviously and being
exposed to students could come
with some risk so but uh you've had
you've had a very
legendary career i want to take you back
uh to your earliest uh you know kind of
a love of physics what inspired you
about
physics and in particular theoretical
physics what is it about it that is so
uh captivating to you that sustained
such a you know
six decade long career well let me begin
on a rather mundane level
um i went to mit
uh i thought it was going to be an
electrical engineer i didn't even know
that people
studied physics as a full-time career
so when you get there they divide you up
into sections like 30 sections there so
you're in with a whole bunch of other
intended majors
and so during the course of that year
i interacted with them and examined
where my successes were
and i said to myself hey look
all the smart people are doing physics
and
i think i i've done as well as they have
so maybe i should do that too now that's
a
heck of a reason but i
did go into physics in my sophomore year
and met jerry and
so forth and
why theoretical physics i
i don't know i was never a tinkerer i
didn't build uh
radios or anything like that so i and i
like the mathematics
so where else am i going to go
theoretical physics uh
something which has a lot of appeal and
uh
it's been good to me and i had a
full life i guess yeah what
today if you were starting out again and
you uh magically took a pill
uh the hagen pill or whatever and it
transported you back in time
uh to a younger age but in this day in
2020 so
it kept you in time i should say uh what
is the most mysterious
aspect of science physics astronomy or
maybe
biology what fascinates you most that
you would most like to
start your career on if you could from a
pure
intellectual curiosity standpoint
well um i've started that and
what would i do if i were coming of
maturity now
yes and one of the things that i would
probably be carefully considering is
economics
and it's a field which
gives vent to my interest
in mathematics and it's uh
very uh influential
in forming our view of the world right
now so
uh no i probably
would not be a scientist but
uh you never know
and uh and then i just want to finish up
with
if a question i ask many people have
come on the show
uh as you may or may not know the title
of my show is called the into the
impossible podcast
which is a quote from sir arthur c
clarke
who said the only way to find out what
is possible is to venture beyond the
limits of the possible into the
impossible
he also said that for every expert
there's an equal and opposite
expert and the last thing he uh
is kind of known for is of course the
the movie 2001
a space odyssey uh the book that uh was
the
underpinning of that particular film
and in that film i don't know have you
seen the film 2001 a space odyssey by
kubrick
yeah oh yeah so there's this picture and
there's a scene
several scenes with this enormous
monolith this enormous black obelisk
looking thing
where you have in the opening scenes you
have these primates in africa two
million years ago
throwing up a bone and then it turns
into this obelisk and then
eventually the obelisk is also on the
moon and the obelisk
to clark was sort of representative of a
time capsule
put by an ancient alien civilization
with the hopes that it would be
discovered at the right time by by human
beings
and that human beings would learn from
this time capsule i want to ask you
uh feynman once said you know if he
could summarize all of physics he would
say
that everything is made of atoms and
atoms obey the laws of quantum mechanics
what would you put on a time capsule
dick if you knew it had
it would last for a billion years what
statement or phrase or piece of wisdom
or equation
uh would you put on such a such a a
billion
year long lasting time capsule
well i like what you uh quoted of
finement everything's made of atoms and
so forth and
uh but it could also be
appended to that that uh then it's made
of quarks
and what's beyond the quarks and uh
don't stop looking because
our history is such that there's always
something beyond
don't stop looking is perhaps one of the
best pieces of advice
i could ever get i'm so glad i got the
chance to talk to you dick it's been a
fascinating treat a true honor for me
uh you like my late great mentor
jerry garalnick our true mentions
just just ultimate kind of role models
for physicists like me
and young and old and i want to thank
you so much for setting this up and for
making taking time out of your schedule
i wish you good health much success and
perhaps you'll win a nobel prize in
economics who knows
okay
any sufficiently advanced technology is
indistinguishable from
magic
[Music]
if you enjoyed this episode of into the
impossible please subscribe
comment share rate and review for a
chance to win a free copy of our most
recent guest's newest book
send a screenshot of your review to info
imagine.ucsd.edu
we appreciate hearing from you and are
always open to your suggestions for
future episodes
for more information go to
imagination.ucsd.edu
find us on twitter at imagineucsd
watch us on youtube listen on itunes
the impossible is a production of the
arthur c clarke center for human
imagination in the division of physical
sciences at the university of california
san diego
eric vieri director brian keating
co-director
patrick coleman associate director
produced by
stuart valco